Leslee used to be the girl you'd find
dancing on tables loving life and living
it to the full
now after a 20-minute operation to help
cure her mild incontinence she's in
chronic pain she can't walk she's lost
her job and her marriage and is suicidal
I'm not a woman that I used to be I feel
like a helpless no-hoper I thought I
think I'd be better off dead if I felt
like this do you know I mean I don't
want to live like this
honestly when I live like this I want my
old life back
that's it grandma please like tens of
thousands of women in the UK Leslie has
had a vaginal mesh implant for many the
operation is quick and successful but
when it goes wrong the effects can be
catastrophic and leave permanent damage
stress incontinence occurs as a result
of weakened pelvic floor muscles and
ligaments caused by childbirth and with
age the TVT mesh procedure is considered
to be the least invasive surgical option
taking just 20 minutes
a mesh tape made out of plastic is
passed through the vagina and placed
around the urethra to form a sling this
is designed to be permanent and to
support the bladder like a hammock and
this is what mesh looks like it's
supposed to be flexible but when inside
the body can stiffen erode and slice
through organs like the bladder there
are a few manufacturers of mesh and
professor Carl Hennigan an expert in
product safety says problems were first
identified 20 years ago and that
clinical trials only start on average
five years after the mesh is implanted
there's a gap of five years where people
are using some of these products and the
ones that we've drawn or the ones that
fail in them clinical trials they're
left with them because the lifelong
influences they've had the operation
done but they've trials haven't been
done correct on a scale of health
scandals for example algae places how
significant I think this is the worth
one that will
ever see hopefully in my lifetime
because I think the scale of the number
of women that have been affected
affected is it is huge because what
happened is there was a rapid rise that
was unjustified in terms of what the
evidence was showing but somehow waves
of Surgeons adopted this waves of people
were convinced that this is a minor
procedure done on a day case and you'll
be cured immediately and I think at the
end of the day we'll look back and see
this as a real disaster across the world
vaginal mesh is a subject of huge
litigation in the US and Australia here
in the UK class action is being brought
by 300 women against one manufacturer of
mesh Johnson & Johnson lawyers say it
could become the biggest medical case in
UK history probably the most significant
in terms of the number of people
involved that I can think of with the
exception possibly of thalidomide going
back a long time and in terms of the
total potential compensation payments or
but that could run into billions of
pounds which would make it one of the
largest medical cases in history this is
the UK headquarters of Johnson & Johnson
in the two years that I've been covering
the story of mesh implants Johnson and
Johnson have refused to discuss it with
me on camera instead they've sent me
another written statement and in it they
say that their subsidiary company
Ethicon is confident in the positive
impact of their mesh products on the
vast majority of women and in regards to
the legal challenge Ethicon says that
the evidence will show that the company
acted responsibly
this comes as we've learned that 55,000
women across the world are suing Johnson
& Johnson because of their mesh products
the Leslie no compensation will relieve
the pain she suffers for which she has
to take a cocktail of opiate level
medication yeah cuz I'm really sick
every day she says her life has been
destroyed by a quick fix up her
that she didn't need Charlotte Lomas Sky
News